there will be a two-minute silence  to remember and reflect on the more than  seven and a half thousand emergency  services personnel  killed in the line of duty in the last  200 years  during this time the emergency services  flag will be raised over ford house  we pause to think and we give thanks for  all of those who silently go to work day  after day  those who keep us safe  those who rescue us in danger  those  who support us when we are unwell  perhaps this year most of all  we give thanks to all those front line  staff  who have worked tirelessly throughout  periods of lockdown and uncertainty  but we also remember those countless  number of people who work in offices all  those people who support those people on  the front line to deliver these acute  services  but all of them  constantly placing the needs and the  welfare of others before their own